13 en bassnormandie en direct ce jeudi
encore du village des jeux et Castres
mondiaux des jeux qui se poursuivent
aujourd'hui avec l'entrée en piste d'une
dernière discipline l'attelage
l'attelage qui se poursuit en ce moment
même on en parle dans un instant juste
après un regard sur votre actualité
régionale avec d'abord une découverte
canise qui ouvre un espoir pour les 44
millions de malades de la maladie
d'Alzheimer des chercheurs du Centre
d'études et de recherche sur le
médicament de Normandie vienent
d'inventer une molécule qui pourrait
stopper l'évolution de la maladie et
ainsi améliorer la mémoire des patients
g Louis
joamar dans ce ballon j'ai à peu près 20
mg de cette molécule le donpr quelques
milligrammes mais beaucoup d'espoir dans
cette molécule créé ici dans ce
laboratoire cané le voici de près ce
doncopride il permettrait d'agir sur les
symptômes de la maladie d'Alzheimer mais
aurait également des vertus cur
un patient atteint de la maladie per la
mémoire il voit son cerveau atrophier
suite à la destruction de neurones
plusieurs causes ont été identifiées
l'apparition de plaqu cénil d'une part
et la dégénérescence neurofébrinaaire de
l'autre notre molécule le donécopride va
viser les plaques céniles en réduisant
la formation de celle-ci et en
promouvant à la place la formation d'une
protéine qui elle est neuroprotectrice
et c'est donc un bénéfice que va pouvoir
exercer ainsi la molécule le doncopride
a été testé sur des souris elles sont
curieuses et aiment les nouveaux objets
leur comportement a permis de mesurer
leur mémoire che chez ces souris nous
avons pu augmenter leur performance de
mémoire chez les animaux sains en
prolongeant leur capacité de mémoire
dans ce test caractéristique d'autres
essais ont été faits sur des souris
transgéniques présentant des troubles
assez proche d' zer les résultats sur
leur cerveau ont été concluants les
plaques séniles ont été diminué tout a
été publié au Journal de l'Académie des
Sciences des États-Unis reste à
transformer cette molécule en médicament
et c'est là que ça se complique il
manque un ingrédient indispensable
l'argent entre 800 millions et 1
milliard
d'euros on en vient à l'actualité de ces
Jeux desquestres mondiaux avec
l'organisation des Jeux au centre d'un
début de polémique le public et nuancé
quant aux qualités de cette organisation
et la presse étrangère n'est pas tente
vous allez l'entendre reportage de
pierremie PU et de Guillaume
Leck 12h30 fin des épreuves matinales
les spectateurs du stade d'an sont priés
de sortir sur l'esplinade les filles
d'attente sentrecroise il y a ceux qui
espèrent déjà la réouverture des portes
et ceux qui veulent
manger
et aussi pour retourner au
stade comme comme
ça c'est pas terrible qu'on puisse pas
manger dans l'enceinte pour désaltérer
avoir une
boisson faire la queue les magasins sont
débord pourtant les organisateurs
viennent juste d'installer des points de
restauration supplémentair ainsi que des
toilettes on est au standard
international pour ce type d'événement
on est dans une transformation d'un
stade de football dans un site équestre
donc les solutions on été apporté
aujourd'hui voilà on a des spectateurs
qui sont heureux la Normandie accueille
le monde samedi l'acheminement des
spectateurs au har Dupin a tourné au
fiasco des milliers de personnes ont
erré à pied après avoir patienté des
heures dans les embouteillages dans la
salle de presse les journalistes
étrangers dresse constat à Cap
Blanc on a souvent entendu parler des
jeux de 1994 à la en Hollande qui était
épouvantable et là les journalistes
hollandais se réjouissent parce que
finalement ces jeux en France c P
lesandais finissent même par être MOS
mauvais mais c'est une honte 94 cétait
il y a 20 ans ça qu mme temps de pas
reproduire les mes
erreurs et sur internet des articles
brocard l'accueille à la française
toilette à ciel ouvert ou à la turque
nourriture h de prix transport défaant
les pires jeux de l'histoire écrit ce
journal
australien j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont
la D maison le comité
d'organisation CIT aussi à s'adapter et
à prendre en compte toutes ces toutes
ces demandes qui qui AFF flu du monde
entier en première semaine donc le
niveau a été relevé était déjà au bon
niveau il a été relevé encore en fin de
journée devant le stade à l'arrêt de la
navette c'est la
confusion donc l'arrê ici est
supprimé c'est précisé non c'est pas
précisé évidemment c'est pas précisé 700
m plus loin la foule tombe ENF sur la
navette arrêt improvisé au bord du
giratoire il n'y aura pas de place pour
tout le monde
les jeux côté sport à présent on va
parler atelage ce midi avec notre invité
Adrien Godin de Villain juge national
élite d'attelage bonjour on vous
retrouve dans dans un instant Corine
benosa bonjour car l'attelage a débuté
ce Matelin avec le dressage d'abord oui
et l'atelage herwan ça sec court en
trois épreuves le dressage c'est la
première qui est noté sur la précision
dans le tracé des figures et aussi
l'esthétisme de l'ensemble alors pour
les gens qui ne connaissent pas allez
voir ça c'est magnifique quatre chevaux
un meneur deux groom les Français qui ne
sont pas les favoris ont engagé h
attelages sur 46 c'est une discipline
qui se développe et ce matin vous allez
le voir là c'est le meneur du Berry
thbaau coudri qui a déroulé cette
reprise vous le voyez là longue de près
de 8 minutes thbao et bien c'est un
ancien rugbyman il faut de la poigne
pour tenir quatre chevaux comme ça enfin
ce sont les Hollandais qui dominent
cette discipline par équipe Adrien Godin
de de vilen je le disais vous êtes juge
national qu'est-ce qui se juge sur une
épreuve de dressage comme celle-ci alors
sur le sur une épreuve de dressage comme
nous voyons aujourd'hui se juge à la
fois l'esthétisme comme vous l'avez dit
principalement l'ensemble le coup d'œil
la l'adéquation entre l'attelage et les
chevaux de même on va juger de des
allures des chevaux de la précision de
leurs allures de leur engage
on va juger également la précision des
figures on on va en parler de tout ça
dans un instant juste après un reportage
pour vous présenter cette discipline de
l'attelage le parents pauvre des sport
équestres en France une discipline
pourtant assez spectaculaire et l'une
des plus pointu de ces jeux reportage
Catherine JeanMichel guilla et Jacques
V à l'arrière les timoners ils sont la
propulsion de l'attelage et doivent donc
être puissant à l'avance il a volé la
direction on attend de ces chevaux qu'il
soi intrépide qu'il n'it peur de rien
pour aller partout où le meneur veut les
guidé longueur totale de l'attelage 12 m
pour une largeur d'1,58 a dirigé le plus
rapidement et le plus précisément
possible au long de trois épreuves
test le dressage c'est des figures
imposées sur une carrière qui fait 100
par 40 m et les qure chevaux doivent
être sur la même ligne de conduite on ne
doit en boire qu'un en fait ensuite il y
a l'épreuve du marathon donc c'est
l'épreuve la plus sportive celle qui
demande beaucoup d'énergie aussi bien au
menur qu'au chevau et ensuite le dernier
test la maniabilité c'est là que tout se
perd ou tout se gagne faut qu'on plus 10
cm par rapport à la largeur des voitures
donc il font 1,58 donc vous avez des
porte à 1,68 et donc ça vous laisse
quand même que 5 cm de chaque côté du
cône et il faut y arriver très très
précisément et bien en face pour façon à
pouvoir les passer sans sans faire
tomber le balle sans faire tomber le
cône ni la plaque de numérotation de de
la porte de l'obstacle
les places des chevaux ne doivent rien
au hasard elles se déterment selon le
caractère la personnalité et les
aptitudes de chacun c'est au meneur de
connaître suffisamment bien ses
partenaires pour construire l'attelage
le plus performant possible c'est des
heures et des heures et des heures de
travail et de répétition aussi bien on
dresse en attelage à on éduque en
attelage en père et on performe le tout
dans l'attelage
à autrefois les menurs avaient h guides
dans les mains ils passaient leur temps
à les prigner comme ils disaient dans
leur jargon aujourd'hui le matériel a
fait de gros progrès les menurs n'ont
plus que qu guides en
mainid sont en bas ici me permettent de
conduire les chevaux de derrière donc
les timoners et les guides qui sont en
haut me permettent de conduire les chev
de volet donc par un système de boucle
comme ceci par exemple si je boucle à
gauche et que je suis un petit peu en
résistance sur la guide de droite au
niveau des timoniers mes timoners vont
partir un tout petit peu sur l'extérieur
mes chev de volet vont venir un peu sur
l'intérieur donc du côté gauche et
l'idée c'est que la tête des chev de
devant jusqu'à l'arrière de la voiture
sur une courbe tout le monde passe sur
la même ligne à fournir tant d'effort
les équipages seront contrôlés plusieurs
fois par jour par les vétérinaires des
jeux car nous sommes en Championnat du
Monde les parcours sont très techniques
et difficiles pas question de faire
n'importe quoi avec les chevaux le
président du jury l'allemand Klaus
Christ y veillera personnellement des
meneurs on attend maîtrise de soi force
endurance et tactique sportive un
mélange de concentration et de
réactivité qui fait sans aucun doute de
l'attelage l'une des disciplines les
plus intéressantes des jeuxéquestres
Mondiaux Adrien Godin de Villet on le
dit parfois l'attelage reste le parent
pauvre des sport etqu en France c'est
votre c'est votre avis c'est un peu mon
avis et je crois que c'est partagé par
tout le milieu de l'attelage c'est vrai
que pour avoir des piquets comme nous
avons là de qu chevaux ou CIN chevaux ça
demande des engagements financiers
énormes et
principalement des sponsors privés
permettent de le faire peu de meneurs
sont professionnels peu de meneurs
peuvent être professionnels parce que
c'est vrai que non c'est en France c'est
c'est c'est pas envisageable avec qure
chevaux c'est une discipline qui coûte
très cher ça revient très cher
heureusement cette année il y a eu quand
même des aides énormes de
l'IFCE enfin les anciens aras nationaux
qui ont mis à disposition des chevaux
pour différents meneurs mais sans ça on
est absolument incapable c'est c'est
plus de 100000 € par an alors on a vu au
Jeux séquestr mondiaux de la clash c'est
tris discipline on a vu le le dressage
il y aura la maniabilité et le marathon
voilà demain nous aprèsdemain pardon
samedi nous aurons le marathon marathon
qui est une épreuve d'endurance comme
comme son nom l'indique qui est une
épreuve qui va se dérouler sur trois
phase une phase de d'échauffement en
fait une phase de transition puis la
phase d'obstacle en elle-même dite phase
B qui verra h obstacles et la
maniabilité très spectaculaire aussi
alors la maniabilité c'est en dernier
c'est très spectaculaire et c'est je
pense celle qui a le la plus grosse
pression au niveau no il y a des des
chances de médailles françaises sur ces
jeux je pense qu'on peut avoir mettons
peut-être meilleur marathon on peut
avoir de très très bonnes
maniabilité je pense qu'il faut être
réaliste et je ne pense pas que au
niveau du dressage on soit encore tout à
fait au top Merci à VOUS Adrien Godin de
de Villen d'être venu nous parler
atelage ce midi dans le 1213 Corine 2e
discipline en piste cet après-midi la
voltige avec des médailles françaises en
perspective deux Français sont en tête
en individuel homme oui ja Ferrari
pardon en P position c'est facile
fallait la faire devant Nicolas Andreani
la French Touch la vraie creuse encore
l'écart avec les Allemands voilà des
images du premier Jacques Ferrari des
costumes toujours superbes et une
chorégraphie impeccable et puis Nicolas
Andreani dans son personnage d'instein
qui lui vous allez le voir dans quelques
secondes à juste raté sa
sortie hop il va partir dans les airs et
hop se réceptionner sur ses deux mains
par terre n'empêche il reste deuxè la
voltige qui reste qui reprend pardon à
partir de 14h au Zénit et les finales
deains de la voltige par équipe parmi
les 10 nations qualifié la Nouvelle
Zélande une équipe venue de très loin
pour ces Jos cast et pourtant certains
proches des cavaliers n'ont pas hésité à
faire le déplacement ainsi oruré miserie
et cy pchel ont suivi de mamans très
très Fiè de leur progéniture regardez
ce n'est pas la distance qui all les
découragerour PR de 20000 K julim
Sonta que de M les PR de
leatione être venu si j'avais d regarder
la compétition depuis chez moi être
là-bas loin plutôt qu'ici et bien non je
suis c'est le jour du programme libre
des
é julim ser
de
mais un plus
[Applaudissements]
fort
[Musique]
voilà c'est maintenant c'est pour ce
moment qu'on attend travailler donc
bonne
[Musique]
chance
commenté TR
[Applaudissements]
bien vous êtes
super j'arrive pas à y
croire je pleure parce que cela
représente les dernières années de ma
vie mais celaait le
coup j'ai encore du mal à croire et on
va en
[Musique]
[Rires]
final voilà c'est ça aussi les jeuxest
Corine au programme de l'après-midi
également la suite de l'épreuve de ce
d'obstacle avec la finale par équipe
tout va se jouer cet après-midi ou là
c'est du sérieux Air One la France est
4e au classement provisoire juste
derrière les Allemands les Américains et
les Hollandais qui sont en tête les
tricolores pour l'instant à moins de qu
points de la médaille d'argent
c'est-à-dire à moins d'une barre à deux
barres de l'or et cet après-midi il va
absolument falloir aligner les sans
fautes pour les quatre Français parmi
lesquels trois banormands le parcours
sera à 1 M60 de hauteur avec des
obstacles très impressionnants pour les
chevaux il y a déjà eu pas mal de de
refus et de chutees on va compter sur
Patrice zavau et son fantastique étalon
Orient Express sans faute depuis le
début de la compétition et premier au
classement individuel rappelons que les
Français étaient médaille d'argent par
équipe au précédent jeosquestre
alexington et puis dernière petite info
l'un des meilleurs mondiaux l'écossais
Scott bras s'esttiré de la compétition
merci Corine le saut d'obstacle qui voit
aujourd'hui arriver une nouvelle classe
de cavalier sous le regard bienveillant
de l'ancienne garde trois ancien
assistaient ainsi mercredi à la première
manche du Jumping par équife ils étaient
bluffés par la piste le public les
obstacles mais aussi et surtout la
qualité et le niveau de la compétition
reportage Catherine et Jean-Michel
guilla pierre Duran éc navet et Nelson
Poa trois légendes du SO d'obstacle
assis côte à côte St d'Ornano une image
pour l'histoire c'est de plus jeun
cavali sont àamp aujourd'hui pour les
championnats du monde c'est que ces tro
là ont ouvert la voix d'un sport
difficile exigeant parfois un GR
toujours exaltant moi les je toujours
réussi et ça ça la de poule parce que
j'ai moimême participé à ces événements
là et avoir ça chez moi devant mon
public
extraordinaire saute plus mais cela
n'entamment rien leur passion pour
l'équitation les temps ont changé le
niveau s'est amélioré la concurrence
s'est développé ce qui reste imuable au
fil du temps c'est le lien si
particulier qui unit cavaliers et
chevaux notre sport à haut niveau c'est
c'est de l'horlogerie il y a de plus en
plus de cavaliers exceptionnels qui
viennent avec des chevaux qui sont mieux
en mieux préparés et qui sont de plus en
plus qui sont de plus en plus complices
on voit des choses magnifiques quoi de
che er navet un grand plaisir au
contraire avoir de jeunes cavaliers
performants assurer la relève il faut
bien que la route tourne dit-il pour la
pérénité du sport l'idéal c'est les
équipes un peu mixées avec des cavaliers
de grande expérience et des cavaliers
des cavaliers jeunes parce que en plus
ces cavaliers plus jeunes ça leur permet
de progresser plus vite d'être au côté
de cavalier plus expérimentés et leur
expérience à eux ces trois inoubliables
champions leurs exploits passés
resteront c'est sûr à jamais des modèles
à suivre pour des générations
entières toujours en direct des Jeux
équestres mondiaux VO allz faire un tour
dans le village maintenant on va
retrouver Hélen jacqu hen qui s'est
invité aujourd'hui au repas des
bénévoles bonjour heran bonjour à tous
et ben oui je me suis invité au repas
des bénévoles c'est quand même l'heure
du déjeuner et ça tombe bien parce
qu'ici tous les jours en cuisine dans
les coulisses du village et ben ça
prépare et ça prépare plein de choses
des bons plat pour tous ces bénévoles
alors bonjour Paul vous êtes le
responsable logistique des gemes
directeur combien de repas on sert ici
chaque jour on sert à peu près 5000
repas sur les cinq restaurants qui sont
sur les C sites de compétition et ici au
village ici au village des jeux c'est
l'équivalent de 1500 à 2000 repas jour
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a au menu nous on
a déjà choisi un tomate mozzarella la
petite tarte la petite tarte à l'abricot
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a ce midi
aujourd'hui c'est c'est varié comme tous
les jours on a une base poisson ou alors
du poulet on peut effectivement aussi
choisir des produits des produits
laitiers des produits protéinés hein
pour les sportifs et c'est important
aussi de faire le plein d'énergie pour
pour les bénévoles alors il y a pas que
des bénévoles qui mangent ici il y a
aussi les gens de la Fédération il y a
aussi les gens du comité d'organisation
mais c'est pour tout le monde le même
menu vous éer on y tient et puis on
essaie surtout en tout cas de de varier
le menu quotidiennement il y a des gens
qui sont là depuis plusieurs jours donc
c'est important de varier qui est la
qualité et la quantité faut que ça
tienne au corps moi je vais vous prendre
je prendrai bien du poisson là voilà le
saumon ça a l'air très bien et vous vous
prenez quoi et ben moi c'est sera poulet
ah voilà et puis il y a une petite
surprise aussi qui attend les bénévoles
aujourd'hui he juste là derrière c'est
quoi mais on fait notre 75 mile repas
aujourd'hui donc pour les bénévoles
depuis le début de l'entrée en jeu des
bénévoles exactement donc on a une
petite surprise surtout un gros
remerciement alors on va leur donner un
peu de magnésium pour les TR qu derniers
jours Merci à VOUS Hélène et et bon
appétit c'est bénévoles sont également à
l'honneur sur notre site internet
bastirnormandie.france3.fr le site vous
propose ce midi une galerie de portrait
de ces bénévoles Christian joupin
bonjour les jeux et castes continuent
cet après-midi sur 3 avec le service des
sport aux alentour de 15h avec une
après-midi placée un peu sous le signe
du rock and roll puisque nous allons
inviter Louis Bertignac un homme de
cheval très impliqué dans le milieu des
troturs il va nous livrer aujourd'hui
une expertise surtout sur cette 2è
journée de sa d'obstacle hier avec la
performance des Français on reviendra
sur les fautes commises sur nos chances
pour cet après-midi puisquélas avec le
French Flair si j'ose dire les
compétitions été reporté donc vous aurez
un résumé complet de la journée bien sûr
dans tout le sport au niveau national ce
soir merci euh à vous Christian merci à
toute l'équipe de franceç et des sport
qui nous accompagne sur ces journaux en
direct de Jos castremondio une petite
information avant de se terminer de se
quitter en marge de ces jeux séquestres
sachez que les transports publics canis
seront gratuits samedi à l'occasion du
dernier samedi de compétition merci de
votre attention le 1213 se poursuit dans
un instant avec la météo puis votre
journal national ce soir vous retrouvez
Émilie Flo pour votre 191 depuis les
Jeux séquestres très bonne journée à
tous et à demain
[Musique]
Mutualia complémentaire santé et
prévoyance vous présente la
météo bonjour sur les
de